[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit 1 wolf
und marietta slomka
guten abend im privaten umfeld zu sagen
ich bin geimpft ist für die meisten
geimpften er eine selbstverständlichkeit
schließlich können sich andere damit
sicherer fühlen wenn man ihre wohnung
betritt oder gemeinsam am tisch sitzt
und den impfausweis beziehungsweise qr
code bei auslandsreisen im kino oder an
der eingangstür eines pflegeheimes
vorzuzeigen ist für viele auch schon
normalität geworden ob aber auch
arbeitgeber ihre belegschaft fragen
dürfen wer gegen korona geimpft ist
steht auf einem anderen blatt mit
wenigen ausnahmen ist das bisher nicht
erlaubt die bundesregierung hat heute
bei der verlängerung der korona
arbeitsschutzverordnung an dem punkt
auch noch keine änderungen vorgenommen
aber
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen will
prüfen ob eine solche
auskunftspflicht am arbeitsplatz
eingeführt werden kann oliver deuker
berichtet die firma nass magnet in
hannover rund 300 mitarbeiter die
leistungsstarke magnetventile und
stecker verbindungen entwickeln und
fertigen die idee dass arbeitgeber den
corona impfstatus ihrer mitarbeiter
zumindest in den kommenden sechs monaten
abfragen dürfen sieht der chef der firma
mit gemischten gefühlen da schlagen zwei
herzen in meiner brust zum einen bin ich
sehr dafür dass die privatsphäre
geschützt wird dass die persönlichen
daten geschützt werden zum anderen muss
ich aber auch sagen als verantwortlicher
für ein unternehmen ist es mir wichtig
dass die gesundheit der mitarbeiter
geschützt wird an der nachher natürlich
auch die effektivität und die
arbeitsplätze und die wirtschaftlichkeit
des unternehmens auch mit dranhängen zu
sehen ist die allermeisten arbeitgeber
bestätigen unter anderem die
unternehmerverbände niedersachsen und
fordern schnelle fanden die unternehmen
sehen das als längst überfällig wir
müssen hier ordentliche schutzkonzepte
für die kollegen in den unternehmen
haben und das geht nur wenn man weiß wer
es geimpft wer es nicht geimpft nur dann
hat kann man den schutz der kollegen
auch wirklich sicherstellen der
betriebsrat von nas magnet hält dagegen
ist damit auf linie mit dem deutschen
gewerkschaftsbund
es geht überhaupt nicht gibt menschen
die eine krankheit haben und sich
dadurch nicht impfen lassen können oder
diesen schwanger und dieses wurde dem
arbeitgeber dann bekannt gegeben werden
und
dadurch könnten den kolleginnen und
kollegen nachteile entstehen der
bundesarbeitsminister auf wahlkampftour
niedersachsen am morgen stellte er im
kabinett den entwurf seiner neuen
arbeitsschutzverordnung vor darin stets
war der impfstatus da vom arbeitgeber
berücksichtigt werden sofern bekannt
allerdings gibt es keinen allgemeinen
auskunftsanspruch gegenüber dem
arbeitgeber das sind sensible dinge
arbeitgeber dürfen auch nicht die
krankenakten von beschäftigten einsehen
aber in den bereichen in denen es
notwendig ist zum beispiel auch in
krankenhäusern oder in gefängnissen kann
ich mir vorstellen dass wir im rahmen
des infektionsschutzgesetz ganz
pragmatische lösungen zu bekommen die
wünscht sich auch unternehmer klaus
kirchheim wüsste er den impfstatus
seiner mitarbeiter könnte er innerhalb
der schichten einen umkämpften mit
mehreren geimpften arbeiten lassen so
dass das risiko dass ein ungeimpfter
sehr viele andere ungeimpfte ansteckt
stark reduziert wird das ist die eine
möglichkeit die andere möglichkeit ist
dass wir im angestelltenbereich
natürlich auch mit homeoffice
gegensteuern können und die leute die
nicht geimpft sind vermehrt ins home
office schicken
auskunftspflicht beim impfstatus
europäische und deutsche gesetze
verbieten das bisher ob man einen
solchen tabubruch befristen kann
sagen wir machen jetzt mal sechs monate
versuchsweise in dem bereich einen
vorstoß habe ich meine zweifel ich
glaube tabu sind sinnvoll und man sollte
sie nicht brechen eine politische
entscheidung ist gefragt die rechtlich
haltbar sein muss so lange setzt man bei
den meisten unternehmen weiterhin auf
testen was bleibt ihnen sonst übrig
darüber wollen wir noch ein wenig reden
christian decker von unserer redaktion
recht und justiz ist bei uns wie wird
das denn wieso ganze problematik unter
juristen diskutiert das wird sehr
unterschiedlich beurteilt also
prinzipiell kann man sagen hier stehen
sich zwei verschiedene interessen
gegenüber auf der einen seite die das
interesse der arbeitgeber die in ihrem
betrieb bestmöglich kroner infektionen
verhindern müssen wenn man sich jetzt an
guckt
großraumbüro oder in der produktion
am fließband wo keine abstände
eingehalten werden da es der impfstatus
natürlich eine relevante information und
die arbeitgeber haben natürlich auch
eine fürsorgepflicht gegenüber ihren
beschäftigten und auch gegenüber
kundinnen und kunden auf der anderen
seite steht das interesse der
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
solche gesundheitsdaten wie der
impfstatus das sind eben sehr sensible
sehr private persönliche daten die den
arbeitgeber jetzt prinzipiell erst mal
gar nichts angehen daraus kann man
nämlich schlüsse ziehen also wenn ich
zum beispiel einmal geimpft wurde weil
ich chronischen hatte und genesen bin
könnte der arbeitgeber daraus den
schluss ziehen dass ich vielleicht ein
höheres risiko für eine long cobit
erkrankung habe und das sind für
arbeitgeber natürlich schon interessante
informationen und diese beiden
interessen müssen eine ausgleich
gebracht werden juristinnen und juristen
nennen das die verhältnismäßigkeit eine
komplexe materie sagen ja befürworter
einer solchen auskunftspflicht dass es
doch eigentlich widersprüchlich ist man
muss seinen ausweis vorzeigen wenn man
beim bäcker kaffee trinken will aber in
einem großraumbüro wo ich viel länger
und mich aufhalte dann darf noch nicht
mal danach gefragt werden was sagen
juristen dazu naja wenn man genauer
hinschaut ist das nicht so ein großer
widerspruch weil wenn ich ins restaurant
gehen dann zeige ich einmal meinen pass
vor ich gehe vielleicht auch nur einmal
in meinem leben in das restaurant das
wird dort auch nicht gespeichert zu
meinem arbeitgeber habe ich aber ein
sehr viel engeres verhältnis vielleicht
arbeite ich da noch 20 oder 30 jahre
lang deshalb ist es schon relevant
welche informationen gespeichert werden
und jetzt mit blick in die zukunft wie
wahrscheinlich ist dass dass es da jetzt
eine gesetzesänderung geben kann na ja
in erster linie ist das eine frage des
politischen willens aber natürlich
musste eine gesetzesänderung den
rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen genügen
und wenn man sich diese
verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung also diesen
ausgleich der beiden interessen anguckt
dann wird es wohl eher so sein dass eine
pauschale abfrage nicht möglich ist dass
alle in den status von allen erfragen
können der gesetzgeber wird hier so ein
bisschen eingrenzen müssen also dass
auch sensible bereiche zb beschränkten
klare regeln vorgeben welche daten will
dürfen wie lange wo gespeichert werden
danke für die einschätzung christian
decker und zu dem thema gibt es nach dem
heute-journal update auch noch ein
gespräch mit einem mitglied des
deutschen ethikrats
vergesst uns nicht das hören auch unsere
reporter und kamerateams immer wieder
wenn sie in den orten der
flutkatastrophe unterwegs sind die sind
nicht mehr täglich in den nachrichten
doch die betroffenen sind weiterhin
jeden tag damit befasst mit der trauer
um die toten mit der erinnerung kann
eigene todesangst mit dem schock über
die unfassbare zerstörung die das
hochwasser angerichtet hat man muss sich
nur die bilder noch mal vor augen führen
wie es beispielsweise in schuld im
aartal außer am tag nach der flut viele
der bewohner stehen seitdem praktisch
vor dem nichts es ist buchstäblich
nichts mehr da was ihr zuhause oder ihr
betrieb waren
das land rheinland pfalz gedachte heute
mit einem staatsakt am nürburgring der
toten und der flut geschädigten davon
berichtet susanne gelhard
ursula ingrid j
ulrike therese richard und mark j es ist
die langen namensliste der toten die das
ausmaß der katastrophe zeigt sie trauern
gemeinsam angehörige der toten und
verletzten hilfskräfte
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeister von
über 250 betroffenen orten
früher unsere launige weggefährten ist
mit all ihren zuläufen zu einem monster
geworden zu einem brutalen
ungeheuer
134 tote forderte die flut allein in
rheinland pfalz hunderte verletzte
traumatisierte angehörige die
verzweifelt zurück bleiben wie wilfried
laufe der von seinem vater durch das
wasser getrennt wurde und ihm nicht
helfen konnte als er ertrank ich kann
ihnen nicht sagen was ich eigentlich
gefühlt habe
war es wut war es die unendliche
hilflosigkeit nicht bei meinem vater
gewesen zu sein die ihn nicht habe
helfen zu können ich weiß es nicht
drei tage später wurde mein vater 25
kilometer abwärts gefunden gedenken und
blick in die zukunft wann staatsakt ging
es auch um den wiederaufbau einer schwer
getroffenen region
eine landesregierung wird alles dafür
tun dass die alte heimat auch die neue
heimat sein kann
wir wollen zusammen mit den kommunal
verantwortlichen und allen menschen vor
ort ein aartal mit zukunft aufbauen
tausende helfer sind über wochen vom
nürburgring aus zu den menschen ins tal
gefahren nun sei es aufgabe der politik
daran anzuschließen meinte ein vertreter
wir erwarten anstrengungen
von unserem land uns die besten
ingenieure die besten fachleute
die besten kapazitäten die dieses land
hier zur verfügung hat zu uns zu
schicken und uns zu helfen schnelle
finanzielle hilfe sei jetzt nötig sagte
der bundespräsident und solidarität das
unheil das über sie hereingebrochen ist
es geht uns alle an wir alle müssen uns
die frage stellen
was können wir tun um auf solche
katastrophen auf solche
extremwetterlagen besser vorbereitet zu
sein
menschlichkeit zusammenhalt weitblick es
war eine starke botschaft die von diesem
staatsakt ausging
[Musik]
hochwasserkatastrophe kroner pandemie
und zuletzt noch das afghanistan
desaster das letzte amtsjahr von angela
merkel hat es auch noch mal in sich
hatte vor ein paar wochen gefragt wurde
wie sie sich fühlen werde wenn sie nicht
mehr kanzlerin ist sagte sie ihre würden
wahrscheinlich aus gewohnheit immer noch
viele gedanken kommen was sie jetzt so
alles machen müsste aber dann werdet ihr
schnell einfallen dass das er jetzt
andere machen müssen und das werde er
wohl auch sehr gut gefallen auf jeden
fall wird sie die erste kanzlerin sein
die das amt freiwillig verlässt und wer
immer merkel nachfolgt übernimmt ein
16-jähriges erbe für armin laschet der
für die union das kanzleramt verteidigen
soll macht das den wahlkampf nicht immer
leichter wie er damit umgeht schließt
sich heute abend beobachten als er bei
der vorstellung einer neuen marke
biografie auftrag macht das feld topf
berichtet
ist er ihr legitimer vielleicht sogar
geborene nachfolger oder sind armin
laschet und angela merkel nur zufällig
in der gleichen partei der kandidat
kämpft ja muss kämpfen und eine zeitlang
hatte nicht nur er den eindruck dass
auch gegen angela merkel tun zu müssen
am ende jeder anzetteln immer dinge
übrig und die packen sie dann an die un
spricht war ja gar nicht antrete alles
erledigt wäre aber armin laschet muss
sich eingestehen dass das nicht gegen
die beliebteste politikerin der republik
geht gibt nicht eine anti stimmung ist
muss die kanzlerin weg er ein bedauern
was kommt jetzt
laschet wahlkampf herrscht in diesen
tagen die umfragen sind im keller der
plan vom glanz merkels zu profitieren
scheitert zunächst noch vor zehn tagen
verweigert sie ihre hilfe kategorisch an
das vorgänger die ihre politische arbeit
beenden sollten sich zurücknehmen das
ist meine haltung meine feste
überzeugung alles hat seine zeit es sind
diese augenblicke die lasche wahlkampf
prägen und die ihn von merkel so
unterscheiden das vertrauen in seine
führungsfähigkeit quasi weggespült sie
dagegen wirkt wie eine stütze für die
ministerpräsidentin ja für alle und er
hat plötzlich konkurrenz auch für die
rolle des legitimen nachfolger im trial
versucht oder scholz die lücke zwischen
laschet und merkel zu füllen in der
pandemie habe sich doch gezeigt dass er
der vizekanzler mit merkel den takt
angibt das haben wir gemacht und zwar
auf meinen vorschlag und denen der
bundeskanzlerin haben wir eine
arbeitslose spüren wir eine bundes
notbremse gemacht für armin laschet eine
art politische erbschleicherei und er
wirkt wie befreit dass die kanzlerin
sich jetzt doch noch einsetzt auch wenn
es nur indirekt ist die kanzlerin für
sich hat jedenfalls auch für sie
ungewohnt deutlich gemacht dass das was
er macht wenig mit dem zu tun was sie
gemacht hat ist das nur die inszenierung
des olaf scholz als legitimer nachfolger
die sie dazu treibt oder doch die sorge
dass eine regierung entstehen könnte die
ihrer grundüberzeugung widerspricht am
rande eines besuches des
österreichischen bundeskanzlers macht
sie gestern zumindest eines klar wer
nicht ihr favorit ist wenn man sozusagen
sich auch nicht beruft ist einen
unterschied gibt mit mir als
bundeskanzlerin wurde es nie eine
koalition geben in der die linke
beteiligt ist plötzlich tritt das ein
was selbst die größten merkel kritiker
wie friedrich merz kaum für möglich
gehalten haben nicht nur die kanzlerin
sieht jetzt sehr deutlich was eine
niederlage für die union bedeuten würde
die rolle in der opposition der vorteil
dieser schlechten umfragen für uns ist
dass wir jetzt sehen was denn die
alternativen sein könnten armin laschet
versucht die quadratur des kreises
neuanfang und weiter so in einer person
zu sein in der öffentlichen wahrnehmung
auf werbepostern sind die letzten 16
jahre offenbar ziemlich positiv besetzt
weiter geht's mit den nachrichten heinz
die neue streikrunde der gewerkschaft
der lokomotivführer gdl hat begonnen sie
soll zunächst den güterverkehr betreffen
und ab 2 uhr in dieser nacht soll dann
auch der personenverkehr bestreikt
werden die bahn hat derweil ein neues
angebot vorgelegt sie bietet eine corona
prämie bis zu 600 euro und eine laufzeit
des tarifvertrags von 36 monaten eine
reaktion der gdl liegt noch nicht vor
zur einschätzung der korona lage will
die bundesregierung künftig einen neuen
wert heranziehen die sogenannte
hospitalisierung since i denn sie gibt
an wie viele neue corona patienten in
der letzten woche stationär im
krankenhaus behandelt worden bezogen auf
100.000 einwohner
heute liegt sie bei rund 1,8 das ist
allerdings nur eine tendenz die genaue
zahl steht erst mit mehreren tagen
verzögerung fest der bislang höchste
wert war an weihnachten mit über 15
außerdem meldet das robert-koch-institut
13.500 31 neue corona fälle innerhalb
von 24 stunden die sieben tage
intelligenz liegt jetzt bei
75,7
während es in einigen bundesländern
bereits die möglichkeit für eine dritte
corona impfung besonders gefährdete
menschen gibt wird weiter darüber
beraten nach welchen genauen kriterien
sie angeboten werden soll die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung setzt
auf eine empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission dazu und die stiko plant
offenbar auch zeitnah eine solche
empfehlung abzugeben
die weltgesundheitsorganisation will
sich mit einem frühwarnsystem besser
gegen neue ausbrüche von
infektionskrankheiten rüsten
bundeskanzlerin merkel und whu
generaldirektor zetros haben das
internationale zentrum für pandemie
aufklärung in berlin eingeweiht dort
sollen daten etwa über tiergesundheit
oder ungewöhnliche krankheiten beim
menschen analysiert werden das ziel
risiken frühzeitig erkennen und künftig
schon vor dem beginn einer pandemie
alarm zu schlagen
zu den leider vielen berüchtigten
gefängnissen auf dieser welt gehört auch
das ewin gefängnis im norden teherans
dort sitzen vor allem politische
häftlinge frauen und männer die es wagen
das mullah regime zu kritisieren oder
gegen dessen regeln zu verstoßen immer
wieder gibt es berichte über die
furchtbaren zustände dort nun gibt es
auch bilder eine bislang unbekannte
politische gruppe hat erklärt die
videoanlage des ewigen gefängnisses
gehackt zu haben das filmmaterial aus
den überwachungskameras spielte sie über
ein online konto der nachrichtenagentur
ap zu der chef der iranischen gefängnis
verwaltung hat die echtheit der videos
inzwischen indirekt bestätigt kann man
safari an berichtet ein
mann bricht vor dem gefängnis zusammen
bedieners innere der haftanstalt gezerrt
ein anderer wird von mehreren wörtern
zusammengeschlagen
schockierende bilder aus den
überwachungskameras des berüchtigten
ewin-gefängnis in teheran es sind bilder
die die öffentlichkeit so nicht sehen
soll bilder die bei monika baradar an
schreckliche erinnerungen wecken sie saß
jahrelang im ewin gefängnis wurde
gefoltert
dort gab es systematischer folter
schreckliche folter das habe ich selbst
erlebt lieber auf die füße aufgehängt
mit verbundenen händen das sehen wir in
diesen aufnahmen nicht denn sie zeigen
keine verhörzimmer
dass die welt die bilder zu sehen
bekommt ist einen hacker angriff zu
verdanken der moment der attacke
eine gruppe mit dem namen aller thalia
gerechtigkeit alice hat sich zu dem
cyber-angriff bekannt und das material
einer nachrichtenagentur übergeben
der leiter der iranischen gefängnis
behörde hat inzwischen die verantwortung
übernommen und sich entschuldigt der
stellvertretende justizchef versprach
aufklärung
seit gestern werden sechs aufseher
beschuldigt sie sollen vor gericht
menschenrechtsorganisationen haben die
videos geprüft und warnen sie sind im
grunde genommen auch nur die spitze des
eisberges denn es gibt sehr viele fälle
von denen so wie sie da gezeigt worden
sind und es gibt sehr viele fälle von
denen wir gar nichts wissen in anderen
gefängnissen die zb vom iranischen
geheimdienst kontrolliert werden wo
keine information rauskommen das ewin
gefängnis entstand 1972 unter dem schah
seitdem werden hier vor allem politische
gefangene festgehalten
auch die menschenrechtsaktivisten mehr
als mohammadi hier archivbilder wurde
dort gefoltert im oktober 2020
freigekommen droht ihr jetzt erneut die
haft wir erreichen sie in teheran
das zeigen dieser bilder ist wichtig für
die menschen in iran aber auch weltweit
wir brauchen dringend internationale
hilfe damit diese schrecklichen
folterungen endlich aufhören
die hackergruppe sendet auch eine
botschaft an den neuen iranischen
präsidenten reisig und wirft ihm
menschenrechtsverletzungen vor
also der iranische präsident selbst als
person ist ja für eklatante
menschenrechtsverletzung
verantwortlich wir müssen das thema
menschenrechte in zusammenhang mit dem
iran ganz klar ansprechen nur über das
atom abkommen zu reden ist zu wenig und
wir müssen uns darüber im klaren sein
mit was für ein regime man hier spricht
ein
regime das weiterhin jeden tag dutzende
menschen misshandelt ungestraft
und jetzt gibt es noch mal weitere
meldungen von heinz wolfener geht der
blick zunächst auf die finanzmärkte und
da ging es heute unter anderem morgens
öl und um den preis es stand eine
entscheidung zur fördermenge an und das
wird auch mit blick auf die
inflationsentwicklung aufmerksam
beobachtet man in welche richtung geht
es beim öl ja am frühen abend haben sich
die opec plus staaten mit saudi arabien
russland an der spitze darauf
verständigt was sie im prinzip bereits
vorher festgelegt hatten nämlich eine
ausweitung der täglichen fördermenge von
400.000 barrel hört sich gewaltig an
doch vor allem die usa intervenierten im
vorfeld pumpt doch deutlich mehr rohöl
aus dem boden haben sie gefordert damit
die preise für sprit heizöl gas wieder
fallen und die inflation einbremsen die
usa beklagen inzwischen eine
preissteigerung von 5,4 prozent in
deutschland haben die statistiker
zuletzt eine teuerung von 3,9 prozent
gemessen und geht es nach bundesbank
präsident jens weidmann drohen auch
hierzulande amerikanische verhältnisse
wir rechnen für deutschland zum
jahresende mit raten die in richtung 5
prozent gehen könnten weidmann ergänzte
zwar heute auch das für diese
preisentwicklung vor allem
vorübergehende faktoren verantwortlich
seien unter anderem eben jene
preissprünge beim rohöl doch was wenn
die inflation doch hartnäckiger ist
inzwischen gibt es nämlich auch ganz
andere töne wie die von carlos der wahre
chef des neuen autoriesen still anthes
mit marken wie peugeot und fiat
der portugiese gab jetzt zu protokoll
dass aus seiner sicht die inflation aus
vielen unterschiedlichen bereichen käme
und sich das was er von vielen ökonomen
höhere nicht mit seiner
lebenswirklichkeit decke frank bethmann
vielen dank
das sanierte marine schulschiff gorch
fock ist erstmals nach sechs jahren
wieder in see gestochen
ziel der zweitägigen probefahrt ist
wilhelmshaven dort wird die weitere
ausrüstung des dreimasters erfolgen in
der september soll die gorch fock wieder
offiziell der bundeswehr übergeben
werden bei der sanierung war es zu
zahlreichen pannen und baustopps
gekommen auch die kosten explodierten
von geplanten zehn millionen auf
135 millionen euro
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
35 16 39 48 49 superzahl 0 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
in venedig haben heute die 78
filmfestspiele begonnen in den nächsten
tagen gehen 21 filme ins rennen um den
goldenen löwen den auftakt machten
schauspielerin penélope cruz und
regisseur pedro almodóvar mit ihrem film
materials parallel ass darin spielt cruz
eine von zwei frauen die ungeplant
schwanger werden schon einen goldenen
löwen sicher hat roberto benigni der
regisseur und schauspieler wird für
seine karriere ausgezeichnet das hat die
internationale jury um regisseur bong
joon-ho entschieden
nächste woche kommt bei uns ein film in
die kinos der auf tragische weise gerade
gut in die zeit passt dass die nato
mächte vom schnellen vormarsch der
taliban so überrascht worden warf ja
auch die frage nach den westlichen
geheimdiensten auf waren sie blind oder
wurden ihre warnungen überhört eine
eindeutige antwort steht noch aus bei
einem anderen krieg hingegen weiß man
heute ziemlich genau welcher
geheimdienst wie versagte und auch was
die politik daraus machte als im februar
2003 der damalige us-außenminister colin
powell im un-sicherheitsrat vor
irakischen massenvernichtungswaffen
warnte verwies auf angebliche belege die
der deutsche bnd geliefert hatte und das
waren jedoch so weit man heute weiß
eine wahnwitzige geschichte die als
spielfilm auch genau das ist wahnwitzig
matthias hat sich den film angesehen
die wüsten wuchs 1999 pullach bei
münchen bei und bundesnachrichtendienst
hat man eine heiße spur im moment hat
kein geheimdienst informanten im irak
aber uns ist da jetzt stehe man vor die
flinte gelaufen ein irakischer
asylsuchender ingenieur afi taliban
behauptet in bagdad an der produktion
von biowaffen vor allem antrags
beteiligt gewesen zu sein
über den dungeons okay
für den deutschen agenten doktor wolf
der selbst in ihrer vergeblich nach bio
waffen gesucht hat der ersehnte beweis
für die aussicht auf einen deutschen
pass erzählt im alban saddam hussein
lasse tatsächlich milzbrand erreger
herstellen und zwar mobil auf lastwagen
damit die inspektoren sie nicht finden
trox
endlich ein großer coup für den bnd
nachrichtendienste nicht den besten ruf
hat und
das wissen sie ganz genau und das führt
eben dann auch zu einem gewissen
minderwertigkeitskomplex und deshalb ist
die sehnsucht danach als ganz großer
wichtiger player im geheimdienst spiel
wahrgenommen zu werden dort eben
tatsächlich sehr sehr groß
denn absolut
soll wenn ich auf eine validierung
die heißen informationen werden gleich
ans kanzleramt und die großen
nachrichtendienste geschickt der
irakische informant bekommt den
decknamen curveball und die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft
als dann aber heraus kommt dass der
alles frei erfunden hat will der bnd
sein versagen lieber nicht öffentlich
zugeben
wir können euch in die welt posaunen
dass wir zwei jahre auf eine quelle
gesetzt haben die nur bockmist verzapft
das erschreckende alles daran ist war
den informanten curveball alias rafi
taliban gibt es tatsächlich und die vom
bnd nicht entwertete lüge von den
mobilen waffenfabriken auch sie wird von
den usa als kriegsgrund gegen den irak
benutzt
die quelle war ein augenzeuge ein
irakischer chemieingenieur der diese
fabriken beaufsichtigt hat warum wurde
diese quelle nicht entwertet nachdem die
bundesregierung wusste dass die
amerikaner sie als kronzeuge für diesen
krieg verwenden will und wie passt das
zusammen
mit den öffentlichen erklärungen dass
man gegen diesen krieg ist und dass man
auch alles tut um ihn zu verhindern
ein großartiger film über fake news und
die unrühmliche rolle des bnd vor dem
irak-krieg und dabei eine wahre
geschichte leider
das war es von uns beiden gleich gehts
hier im studio weiter mit den
paralympics und danach folgt das
auslandsjournal unter anderem mit
berichten über die machtübernahme der
taliban und um 0.40 meldet sich dann
christopher wehrmann mit unserem
russischen update
[Musik]
guten abend schon seit zehn tagen liegt
hoch gaia westlich von uns jetzt endlich
kommt es auch nach mitteleuropa das
bedeutet für uns viel sonnenschein und
in der nacht bedeutet es auch oft klaren
himmel in gewässernähe bildet sich nebel
oder dünsten es gibt auch
hochnebelfelder die temperaturen sinken
auf 14 grad an der nordsee und bis 5
grad am alpenrand und morgen liegen sie
dann meist zwischen 20 und 26 grad und
nur im nordwesten bleibt es kühler mit
18 grad denn dort hält sich morgen eine
hochnebeldecke so zwischen hamburg
osnabrück und aurich im süden allerdings
zeigt sich zum teil richtig kräftig die
sonne und so ähnlich geht es dann auch
in den nächsten tagen weiter
temperaturen steigen häufig über 20 grad
und erst am sonntag drohen von besten
gewitter spätsommerwetter dabei ist
heute
meteorologische herbstanfang es beginnt
die zeit von nebel bodenfrost und
herbststürmen bäume sind bei sturm
besonders gefährdet erst recht wenn sie
durch die hitzewellen der vergangenen
jahre vor geschädigt sind woran erkennen
sie das hängt da durchs laub trockenes
laub sind erste abgestorben wenn stamm
oder erste löcher haben könnten sich
schädlinge eingenistet haben tritt harz
aus ist auch das ein zeichen dass der
baum geschwächt ist genau wie pilzbefall
an stamm- oder wurzeln beim nächsten
spaziergang könnten sie ja mal ausschau
halten welcher baum gefährlich ist guten
abend